hi everyone and welcome to West
Yellowstone Montana we are live at the
Grizzly & wolf Discovery Center
sponsored by Microsoft Surface my name
is Kelly Barret I'm here with Sarah and
naturalist here at the center and Sarah
is going to be sharing all about the
grizzly bears here today so just to
start off can you tell us a little bit
about the bears that we'll be looking at
today and how they ended up here at the
center yeah I'd love to although the
first thing I always encourage people to
do is to watch those bears you don't
need to watch us because the bears are
much more exciting so there are three
bears out on the habitat right now they
are Roosevelt Grant and quorum so we
have seven grizzly bears that live here
at the center all together all of the
bears that live here had to come out of
the wild due to some kind of conflict
with humans and none of them can ever go
back out into the wild again
so these bears right now are out here
with all kinds of different enrichment
so we move the bears in and out all day
from their den area which is indoors
bring them out into this habitat in
different groups either one two or three
at a time that's just based on their
size and their temperaments grizzly
bears are by nature are solitary animals
so it's not normal for them to be social
but here at the center all of the bears
are spayed and neutered and of course
they're well fed so we've taken away
most of the reasons they would have to
really fight if they were out there in
the wild which would mostly be fighting
over mating or protecting Cubs or food
sources and so if we can socialize the
Bears here we do again these bears are
Grant and Roosevelt nuts from left to
right the one on the far right with that
cooler is quorum grant and Roosevelt are
here at the center again they are
brothers they're seven years old and
they're from Yellowstone National Park
and when they were first year bear cubs
living in Yellowstone they were orphaned
after Park Service euthanized their
mother due to public safety concerns and
as orphaned bear cubs they could not
stay in the wild without their mother
for protection and
grizzly bear cubs spent two to three
years with their mothers basically
learning all the survival skills it
takes out there they're not a purely
instinctive animal they have to be
taught lots of things like where to find
the berries and when they're right where
the fish are how to build dens and
things like that so grant and Roosevelt
were too young to stay in the wild and
they were removed from the wild by
Yellowstone Park services they arrived
here at the center when they were about
eight months old and that was in late
September 2011 again they're now seven
years old grant over there on the Left
weighs about 475 pounds his brother
Roosevelt is closer to the 600-pound
range which is about an average range
for a male grizzly bear in this area so
again quorum up there he's from corn
Montana and that is more into the
Glacier National Park area and Corp is
what we call a food conditioned bear so
as a wild bear he had gained repeated
access to human food sources a food
conditioned bear is a bear that
associates human populated areas with
food sources so they look for food in
neighborhoods in towns and campgrounds
and this creates a problem so a food
conditioned bear doesn't look for food
in the wild and it's usually very
comfortable around people and eventually
will become a bold and aggressive their
quorum was relocated many times by
Montana Fish Wildlife and Parks but
again he kept going back to those easy
food sources in campgrounds and
neighborhoods and so eventually had to
be removed from the wild he arrived here
early September 2011 at the age of three
and he weighs just over six hundred
pounds as well so these bears are
looking for all the enrichment items
that we have put out here in the habitat
for them Roosevelt already got a
watermelon that we had put out in the
pond and corn has already broken into
one
those coolers so what we do here at the
center is a container testing program
what happens if there's a manufacturer
that has some kind of container and
wants to see if it's bear resistant then
it will bring it to us for testing so it
might be a cooler or a trash can a
dumpster even a backpack or a stuff sack
the point is we want to keep bears from
getting any kind of food reward from
human sources so what we do is we take
the container like that cooler that
grant is starting to work on and we put
some really yummy stuff inside there may
be sardines
kibbles maybe a bone or a fish we want
to make it something they really want
and so they'll work really hard to get
into that container if the Bears here at
the center work on the container for
sixty minutes and don't get a food
reward then that container is considered
to be bear resistant again we want to
keep bears from getting any kind of food
source from human areas we've actually
won some major awards for contributing
to the conservation of wild grizzly
bears through our container testing
program which is in partnership with the
u.s. Forest Service and the interagency
grizzly bear cut committee as well as
the Montana Fish Wildlife and Parks so
we're really proud of our container
testing program there was one question
from the audience about grant and
Roosevelt's mother can you tell a little
bit more about that story yeah so grant
and Roosevelt were first year bear cubs
and their mother was actually associated
with two human fatalities in the summer
of 2011 the first incident was a husband
and wife who had been hiking together
and through a series of unfortunate
events several things happened that
resulted in the mother grizzly bear
grant Roosevelt's mother actually going
after the people who were didn't have
bear spray and we're also running not
too
you know say anything negative about
that because it was an unfortunate event
however it's really important if you're
hiking in bear country to be aware of
those bears chorim's going up that tree
now to be aware of the bears if you see
a bear when you're hiking you should
turn around and go back to the safety of
the trailhead you should definitely
carry bear spray and again if you do run
into a bear in the wild
do not run because that means that bears
gonna chase you you don't want to be any
kind of threat to that bear so because
Park Service had all of the information
from that first incident which resulted
in one death they didn't take any action
against the bear with her cubs because
they realized again through a series of
unfortunate events that the mother bear
was really just doing her job
protecting her cubs but there was a
second incident and in this case there
was a gentleman who was hiking alone
again we discouraged people from hiking
alone in bear country
most bear encounters happen when there's
only one or two people who are hiking or
camping once you have three or four
people you make a lot of noise the Bears
hear you're coming and generally will
get out of your way so this gentleman
was alone in sick their country there
were a lot of bears in the area he was
ten miles into the backcountry and was
encouraged to go out there with the
group but he chose to go alone when they
found him he had already been dead for
about 24 hours and nobody exactly knows
what happened to him there were several
grizzly bears in the area one of them
happened to be grant and Roosevelt's
mother
so again nobody exactly knows what her
role it was if any however at this point
Park Service made the decision to remove
her from the wild and thereby her cubs
as well and some some folks are kind of
asking this distinction between your
center and maybe an other typical zoos
elsewhere talk about what makes this
place special one of the things that I
think makes this place special is again
we do lots of enrichment for these
especially these all the animals here we
want to keep them not just physically
healthy but also mentally healthy so
it's one of the reasons why we move the
Bears in and out of the habitat all day
long and different groupings we can we
change that schedule every day so they
never really know what's happening every
time they come out here we've put all
kinds of interesting things out here we
bury lots of fruits and vegetables under
those rocks and logs we hang stuff in
the trees we give them coolers to test
which is important for testing the
coolers but also it gives the bears some
enrichment there are some fish in the
pond right now I don't think they know
that yet but we do lots of things to
give them enrichment so that's one of
the things we're really proud about
proud of here at the center is the way
that we care for these animals
absolutely so you talked a little bit
about the bears here and what the
typical day might look like for them
yeah so a typical day for these bears
again we're gonna move them in and out
of this habitat area bears in the wild
are not active all the time they're
mostly active in the morning and the
evenings they'll actually spend a lot of
the day in what we call a day bed that
is napping yeah he's he's I don't know
if he's trying really hard to get into
it or just playing with that in the
water but regardless it is fun to watch
so so there's in the wild again they
spend a lot of their days napping
resting they want to conserve their
energy they don't want to expend a lot
of energy theirs are omnivores and we
call them opportunistic omnivores
they're always looking for the easiest
food source with the least caloric
expansion so again they rest a lot in
the wild so here at the center we mimic
a lot of what they would do in the wild
so when they're out here they are more
active they can forage for food very
they can again you know sometimes we put
out different scent things they can roll
it and just their ascent oriented animal
so that's very exciting for them and
then when they're back in their dens
they have toys and food we give them
beds at night and again they can rest
back there which mimics their wild
behavior and I think it's great that you
all do educational activities and
demonstrate
to show people who come back what to do
in the event that they encounter a bear
how to have a proper campsite we had the
demonstration last night on Yellowstone
live about the campsite and how the
bears kind of took that down you want to
speak to that a little bit about how
absolutely again the best way we can
keep wild bears out there in the wild is
by prohibiting them from getting any
food source from a human source ever
bears are very smart and they are single
time learners that means they can get
into a cooler one time and they'll never
forget they can get a bird feeder down
one time and they never forget so the
reason we set up those mock campsites is
to educate people about camping in their
country again if a bear gets into a
campground and gets the food reward that
these Bears got last night which they
got a pretty good food reward then that
bear is very likely to continue to going
into campgrounds to look for food and
that is of course going to create a
dangerous situation for the people there
and ultimately for that bear so when we
set up those campsites it's again to
educate people to be bear aware whether
they're camping hiking any kind of
recreation in bear country and again
that goes for black bears as well as
grizzly bears yeah absolutely
and are these can you talk about the
birds that are also here yeah these
these are Ravens Ravens are scavengers
and so they're doing the same thing here
at the center that they would be in the
wild which is hanging around large
predators like bears and wolves Ravens
are really smart but they cannot you
know kill a fish or take down an elk or
something to that effect so they will
symbiotically with both grizzly bears
and with gray wolves in order to
seed in their own survival so they they
know that they can get food sources
again from maybe a leftover carcass in
the wild and here at the center again
the Bears don't pick up all the food we
put up out there for them so they're
Ravens do not be the cleanup crew I call
them great and some folks are asking if
they are visiting Yellowstone National
Park if they can come by and they're at
a mission knew they need to get to get
some absolutely we would love to have
you come by we're again in West
Yellowstone which is the west entrance
of Yellowstone National Park
we do have an admission in the summer
months were open 8:30 to 8:30 our hours
do change seasonally the admission is
good for two consecutive days so when
you do come to the center you can plan
for that it also allows you to come and
go as much as you like so you can look
at our schedule which again changes
everyday and come participate in
different experiences with the bears the
wolves the UNT ground squirrels and of
course the Raptors and all the different
educational program programming we have
throughout the day absolutely so if
you're watching and following along feel
free to chime in with any comments or
questions we'll try to get to them and
so can you talk a little bit about how
these three are together because I know
earlier one of the Bears was just so low
in the habitat and now there's three
together so they get along well these
days yeah so of course Roosevelt is
backed by those trees he's lighter in
color than his brother grant who's in
the pond
I think Roosevelt's going in the pond
right now and they are siblings now in
the wild they would have split up
probably when they were two or three
years because again bears are solitary
but here at the center they don't need
to go off on their own and so they are
allowed to sort of stay in that sort of
cub like behavior throughout their lives
quorum goes out there with him with
Grant and Roosevelt it's kind of an
unusual relationship if you will quorum
just gets along very well with both
Grant and Roosevelt and the three of
them can sort of interchange
with each other they sometimes all three
play together sometimes the brothers
playing together sometimes quorum plays
with one or the other so it's kind of a
neat relationship that these bears have
and are any of the animals within your
Center
do they ever reproduce or and how does
that work so all of the Bears and the
wolves here at the center are spayed and
neutered so we don't do any breeding
here at the center you know grizzly
bears they can live a very long life an
average wild lifespan for grizzly bear
it's about 15 to 20 years but in
captivity the median lifespan for a male
grizzly bear like these three is
twenty-one for a female grizzly bear the
median lifespan in captivity is
twenty-six now we do have a bear here at
the center named bear 101 and she's 36
years old so that's exceptional so again
a bear can live a very long life and we
prefer to provide a place for a bear to
live that needs a place that that you
know again has to come out of the wild
absolutely yep and so just continuing to
get some questions about some of the
enrichment that you have within the
habitat and you know why do we provide
the coolers and some of the instruction
that you provide yeah so again bears are
very smart and they are always looking
for food in the wild since they're only
up for a portion of the air because of
hibernation then they are very focused
on finding food pretty much all of their
waking hours so again here at the center
we kind of mimic what they would be
doing in the wild the foraging the food
sources we want to keep them moving
around and and getting that good
exercise and not just exercising their
bodies but really exercising their
brains sometimes we put out different
scent and richman again both bears and
wolves are very scent oriented animal so
when they smell something new and
different
it's kind of like when we read a book or
watch a movie and we get all this great
information the other day it was really
windy
Behr's was out just sitting with her
nose in the air for about 20 minutes and
probably getting all kinds of
information bears can smell up to 18
miles away so you can imagine all the
information that they're getting from
all the different sources out there so
we might do scent enrichment like do the
food enrichment again we put things out
there in the pond we get trout donated
from the Anna's fish hatchery so right
now there are some life trout
although the Bears haven't caught them
yet I think grant is there sweet water
call it submarining looking for fish so
he might might catch one and again the
the container testing is actually for
the manufacturers however that container
testing is also more enrichment for the
Bears so lots of different things again
and we hang a bird you know mock bird
feeders up in the trees to teach people
please don't hang bird feeders if you
live in bear country and also to show
that grizzly bears can indeed climb
trees and then of course burying the
food makes them use their noses which
means they use their brains so they have
to find it in forage just like they
would in the wild right well this has
been wonderful thank you so much for
sharing thank you information and
providing this habitat where the grizzly
bears can thrive and as we close up just
another mention for the our sponsorship
with with Microsoft Surface so big shout
out to them and make sure to tune in for
Yellowstone live tonight yeah thanks so
much everyone